say you're sorry just asking you to
apologize you don't got to freak out
anybody oh
hey okay okay what is going on here
why is you screaming cuz he he he hit
mate with a stick and I told him to
apologize what you're feeling now is
what you're feeling
okay let it
out I don't think I don't need you to
think right now Connor you need to
respect your son's autonomy and really
let him process how Crossing this
boundary is affecting his ever evolving
moral code I want my Stu stick where is
it Jack how's Nate doing in school great
you know he's coming along uh how's
how's your little one doing he's great
he's
perfect yeah come on
bro hey hey hey hey